قلق متزايد في اسواق الطاقه من اضطراب في
الاسعار خلال الاشهر المقبله بعد ان فرضت
الدول الغربيه عقوبات جديده على قطاع
النفط والغاز الروسي فاليوم يطبق الاتحاد
الاوروبي ومجموعه السبع واستراليا سقفا
ساريا على مشتقات روسيا النفطيه السقف
السعري تم تحديده على اساس مئه دولار
للبرميل من المشتقات النفطيه ذات العلاوه
السعريه مثل الديزل وخمسه واربعون دولارا
للبرميل للمشتقات النفطيه الاقل جوده
والذي يتم تداولها بخصم مثل زيت الوقود
والنفته ومن المقرر ان تتم مراجعه هذا
السقف في مارسا المقبل
هذه العقوبات ليست الاولى على قطاع الطاقه
الروسي فقد طبقت الدول الغربيه في ديسمبر
الماضي حذرا على النفط الروسي المنقول
بحرا ووضعت ايضا سقفا سعريا عند 60 دولارا
للبرميل لصادره كل ذلك للحد من عائداتها
بسبب الحرب في اوكرانيا فالاتحاد الاوروبي
قدر بان السقوف السعريه تكلف روسيا 175
مليون دولار يوميا ارد الروسي جاء بوقف
توريد النفط من بدايه الشهر الحالي للدول
التي فرضت سقفا سعريا حتى يوليو المقبل
وبدوره قال نائب رئيس الوزراء الكسند ان
تلك الخطوه تاتي للحد من تاثير تلك
الادوات على اسواق النفط التي تشهد حاله
من عدم اليقين مع ما يمر به الاقتصاد
العالمي من تحديات